et là qui nous apportait le beau temps
pourquoi
je viens d'arriver là ouais ouais c'est
beau mais les gars voulaient dire
comme ça sur les photos on a une pensée
la bretagne donc lé peuple breton moi je
préfère la retraite c'est le premier
était comme libres de plus encore vous
enfin il en pense quoi et le vif plutôt
bien et je suis content d'avoir des
parents dans le coup
il faut toujours que tu maintiennent la
lance vers le haut excusez moi je
verrais inscrire mon fils a des leçons
sinon tout ça va tu t'ennuies pas trop
si si j'ai passé mes meilleurs été
sifflé juste vingt fois que tu le dis
qu'est-ce qu'elle ait pas une [ __ ]
vous avez là ben ouais ouais c'est
chelou
en fait c'est drôle de soins métal s'est
fait un live de winne qui j'ai vu aucun
acquis
diane préau c'est un signe du destin
c'est vraiment marrant comme toi et si
je prends un verre là avec un ancien
pote que j'ai rencontrés par hasard raft
et pour l'aéro message que sa
connaissance
attendez moi je vais venir avec vous on
va prendre ma voiture j'ai un peu envie
tu as tout seul en fait ça me dérange
pas si j'écoute un peu de musique
non pas parce que tu sais quoi ça je
crois que ce serait bien que tu lui
dises je présente mon pote raf bonjour
je
content d'être ici avec nous tous les
trois à la en amoureux
sur le scot dormi un peu et ça nous fera
des vacances mais venu justement ici
pour essayer des transports du direct
des filles de mon âge tu me fout la
honte en boîte enfin réveille toi t'as
plus 18 ans papa
arrêtez de me faire chier
et que je cherchais tabou la tire bien